[Music]
[Music]
on reflection I think the lack of budget
might be showing so it's been a little
while since I've logged a couple of
weeks this has been a period where as so
many of you suggest in the comments I
have just been focusing purely on my
thesis I'm not worrying about each EEB
you've probably got to work out when I
film this because it was when I wasn't
really uploading anything other than the
wiki cast I have been focusing on my
thesis and that has been paying
dividends now I'll talk about the
various things that are going on the
thesis later on in the week as we come
to them are you actually join me halfway
through today I'm currently walking back
to unique look that's the more white
balance and pointing difficult it's that
uni and I'm walking back to the Union
because I did a full mornings work
actually a really productive morning
moving around everything in the first
results chapter doing some coding
getting some statistic stuff ready and
bounced to go and yeah just generally
getting getting my life sorted but then
then I went home to drop off
I obviously had to do a few errands
really it's pretty boring in town or the
cat's here so one of the reasons I love
walking along the section of is there
like for cats who are very friendly you
might have seen on my Instagram I got
used as a stepladder by a cat earlier
it's one unlucky
you are just desperate for that
attention on you any day in which you
pet a cat is a good day that's the
second cat of the day for me I've had a
great day what was I saying oh yeah so I
was talking about chosen town yeah
basically I did that uh now I'm going
back to uni I'm gonna pick up some lunch
and it's back to work on some statistics
Oh exciting so I've just got the office
to myself everyone else has left it is
Wow
gonna quarter to six where's everyone
leaving similarly anyway I've got the
office to myself oh I bet it's because
it's dead like savings the outside looks
like that so this is my current working
setup basically I have a plan
in my my notebook which I'm acting on
this computer this is the thesis writing
computer basically just because it's C I
find it easier to do coding on here
there are the reasons but like I find it
easier to do coding on here and to run
stuff from the terminal here and then do
the write-up on here just because you've
got a bigger keyboard so I've been
writing up the new version of chapter
four which is the first results chapter
which I've now got this sort of revised
plan for a lot of it isn't really
changing like the science isn't really
changing I'm adding a column basic
basically what I've done is compared to
things before like observations and
predictions except there's no
observations it's reanalysis but that's
like a whole that's a whole other other
thing I'm comparing observations and
prediction and effectively understanding
another column that run comparing one
set of predictions to another set of
predictions which use less information
and so I'm rearranging what I've done
before and rewriting sections of it so
I've been doing that on here but as
lovely juicy statistics have been
running in the background I've got two
processes running in the background zoom
in on these you've got one process that
this is just working out the standard
deviation of a bunch of data the massive
dataset so it's taking a little while
but that's then saving so I can it's
basically to make things like plots more
easily readable and on this slide
there's another set of PV inversions
because I'm might potentially be adding
yes another column which uses a
different subset of the data would
stopped so today's been a really good
day for the PhD I I think basically I
had two good night's sleep in a row and
I suddenly feel human again I've been
working away through this I feel like
I'm on top of it I've got basically
three I want to be finished in three
weeks and I've got my sort of two
results chapters they are half written
they're in a state of writing basically
doable it's definitely doable in three
weeks I'm gonna be here until about bit
past seven so another another error in a
bit just got a grind now you know the
data is now available one of the one of
the scientific problems with the
chapters I didn't have the right set of
data or either I didn't have enough now
I've got that now I'm writing it up just
got to work and the funny thing is I'm
very good at just working
[Music]
you
[Music]
I think we've already come across the
major problem with vlogging at the
moment which is that my life is
fundamentally quite boring right now
yeah my life is basically here in the
office with my terrible backlighting and
my two computers Sony so many ways you
can film this it's not interesting guys
what is interesting is the fat one
really wonky what is interesting is the
work that I'm doing I'm actually now
somebody commented actually okay I'm
just gonna date this as if I don't they
I literally set the date was somebody
commented saying basically you know are
you just pushing through now you like
you didn't find it's interesting anymore
and the answer that is I think I'm until
recently yeah I just didn't find it
interesting I was bored really bored
after four years of this project and I'm
pretty sure every academic I've spoken
to about this is said when I said I'm
sick of it I'm really sick of doing my
PhD at this point I don't mind admitting
that and they were like yeah that's how
it is for everyone so I don't feel bad
but at the same time recently um it's
got more interesting like re looking for
the the results that actually this new
direction that my second supervisor is
sort of put on the thesis has made it
interesting again which is great like
especially who you call some of the
stuff I talk about what I'm doing
specifically in a later day and in this
episode but suffice to say at the moment
I'm writing up I've got a list that's to
a four pages on of things that I need to
do this week so even lunch in the office
I'm gonna be here late this evening yeah
my life's work
mmm look at that graph isn't that nice
graph Oh inaccurate so we later in the
afternoon it's about half past three
I've just been doing some more writing
up you haven't been missing out on much
much like you haven't been missing out
much in the past few weeks I've been
writing up the first meat section it's
basically finished they need to discuss
one more figure which is currently
generating at the moment rather than
that actually pretty much on schedule
for completing this chapter by the end
of the week things are these are okay
now I'm going to be returning see I look
this time I'm going to be returning to
the office later to do some more work
but for now I'm popping into town let's
do a photo shoot I've agreed to take
some photos with chapter file when they
perform in the Cathedral today so that's
where you're going Wow
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sir the moment the cathedrals decked out
for remembrance which if you're not from
the UK you may not know people who are
poppy as a sign of remembrance below he
died in while conflict generally but
generally is specific the sort of
associated with the first and second
world war specifically the first and so
the poppy has become kind of symbolic of
the Association and so that you've seen
here is there's a lot of them in carpets
especially with this being you know
hundred years on from massive battles in
the first of all pour like Passchendaele
incidentally if you want to learn more
about the First World War I highly
recommend the channel the Great War I
think I've plugged them before but
goodness me fantastic educational
channel Oh gentlemen so it's a kind of
somber quiet time this time of year I
mean it's actually Halloween today which
means that some you know it's some days
until Remembrance although it did notice
back here where are we I was just kind
of absent mindedly looking through the
place there's loads of history it for
example the guy who founded x2 College
Oxford was a bishop here I didn't know
that but is applying here to to people a
completely normal plac to find the
cathedral I notice that the lady died
exactly two hundred and eight years ago
today I'm not - or 31st I discover weird
coincidence well that's done always a
pleasure it's working the cathedrals I
think they had them a selection of
artifacts out from their archives
there's so much history in this building
apart from all the murals in the world
which you saw you know there's lots of
the video one day like the astronomical
clock in there and the sixteenth century
Catholic is so much now though I'm just
gonna pop down to drop off these extra
bits of camera equipment sorry about the
bells and then I'm going to go back to
the office if these things don't drive
me mad in the office again it's
Halloween night and I'm doing the
scariest thing of all which is to sit
alone with my thoughts I am currently
running several scripts at once I am
running I'm running the first version of
this script which is meant to be well
all these pots meant to look like this
one in the middle but with more lines
aren't quite sure why it's not working
that's why this is the first version or
not the final version I'm also running
this little script which is
interpolating some stuff from war
Michael Bay is directing which is
interpolating some stuff from pressure
surfaces on desert surfaces but it's yet
to kind of get going it's been like this
for a while probably cuz I'm creating
quite help hello that's the camera yeah
probably because I'm creating quite a
large dataset and it takes a little
while to kind of you get going and then
on the big old computer I'm also running
something on the cluster which is
another set of inversions the same as
was going yesterday that I probably
finish them like Friday maybe but
basically I'm gonna be here for a few
more hours yet it's just ten seven and
I've got dinner with me I've got this
big old list in my book I'm gonna take
off a bunch of more things because I
need to do that time I think that's the
least of your worries right now
[Music]
okay it's ten o'clock and lots of really
good progress loads of really really
good progress actually smashing through
a bunch of things to doing the to-do
list yet again there are loads of
programs running programs which I it's
well there's most satisfying things in
the world we write computer code and it
running like okay let's you put it
through the terminal in your thinking
let's find the first error and it just
works and it's like oh my god I don't
know a complete idiot I'm recording yeah
so this next section of this chapter
which is looking at mass fluxes using
different data sets this is all stuff
that's gonna hopefully I'll come in
tomorrow there'll be two nice juicy data
sets I can come in and plot nice and
easily and I've got I've actually got
stuff ready like the the plotting code
is written so that's cool yeah really
really really happy with the progress
today
like just noting down it is however ten
and I probably should go home because
I've got more work to do I did that
really funky transition with the
Cathedral I should probably do something
similar here right it's how fast travel
as long as there aren't any enemies
nearby
alright fast travelling to my room go
and we're here in the room this is this
is my butt off she's not even in the x2
anymore and I still kind of fix late fix
her girl's face oh just as I sat down it
changes to me was John Hank green that's
that's a bit better no I didn't mean
like no gonna lie that this was pretty
amazing so this is the kind of time like
11 o'clock thought I would normally be
editing but other projects that kind of
got in the way so first of all I need to
take the files though the photos from
earlier and put them in my Lightroom and
fiddle about with them so they can be
used actually no first of all I need to
change I got these new pyjamas check it
out
yeah I'm importing the photos that's
what I'm saying so the photos have been
imported there's like quite a few of
them from the shoot today it was really
really difficult conditions it was just
so dark you can probably see it in these
pictures this is before any grading but
yeah this was this was really quite
tough these can be graded at some point
in the future because I've got something
else to work on which is ah Beng so
something I don't think I actually ever
mentioned before is well Chapel has a CD
for one thing that's that's definitely
something I've mentioned before I
designed this I didn't record it whereas
normally for all the video and audio
stuff of the chapel I recall it but we
have some guys come in to do it from the
Cathedral but I designed the album art
that's a picture I took of the sunrise
from a field by the Uni and I did the
back and there's also a book clip in
here this one's unopened there's a book
in there with information about it now
two years ago I designed all that in
[ __ ] which is the free version of
Photoshop whereas now I actually have
Photoshop so I'm in the process of
basically doing all that again but I'm
doing it in Photoshop which means it's
so much faster also it has to be faster
because I literally have an hour or so a
day to work on this before I go back
it's come together pretty nicely though
if I may say so myself considering I
taught myself to use this program last
week I'm pretty pleased so this is all
subject to home zoom in a little bit so
this is all subject to change but this
is probably what this the CD cover is
gonna vaguely look like it's really
really cool to be able to just construct
because this is completely constructed
if I go through and like build
everything up in the background there's
a photo which is got like what's it
called this is where my lack of
knowledge of the program shines through
and opacity mask that's the one and then
various like smart filters applied to it
but then on top of that then there's
also light and that comes in different
flavors like there's different gradients
and sort of fake bakka in there and then
there's some cloth in there which was
originally a completely different sort
of well it's not even that color for one
thing it's that
that then gets graded and then there's a
snowflake which goes on top of it I'm
probably not real interested in this
I'll be honest but to me it's cool and
then of course you got the text at the
top like I think I've done a fair Louie
I think and I've done a fair bit of
design work in my time Italy not using
the software I think this is one of my
best things my best bits of man I'm
gonna call it up you know I mean best
bits of work
see yeah if you're wondering why I
haven't been editing it's been because
of this because of the CD and that's
been keeping me awake so I'm gonna do
about another hour or so this and then
I'm gonna go to bed really exciting go
to work tomorrow it's gonna be good
we're gonna get this thesis done
[Music]
someone else's headed out to lunch which
is why I am now free to talk to you and
look there's a lion outside I'm actually
well lit there's a decent contrast to me
the background like I dunno undo when it
comes to for camera work I just I don't
normally film during the day because I'm
normally here at night that doesn't even
make any sense or why I'm tired so this
morning I have been working surprise
surprise on the next section of the
thesis which is the mass fluxes I just
got something working before basically
basically these curves represent
different things let's look at the top
one so this represents the density
anomaly at 20 kilometers in the
atmosphere so this is longitude this is
along the line of constant latitude 65
North wrapping around the pole so the
observations this is calculated in
hydrostatic relation those of you
wondering are in black and then these
are two different approximations using
two different bits of information
basically the blue line is using
information from the whole atmosphere
and one of the things I'm doing in this
thesis one of the key things is working
out whether you can do some calculations
using just information from the
stratosphere which is what the little
subscript s stands for so the red curve
is pretty close to the blue curve so in
this case 20 kilometers out it's in the
stratosphere so you kind of hope that
come on focus you can't pay for the
stratospheric stuff would work so this
is for the it's different but there is
there is still a fundamental error
between these two new observations and
that's bigger when it comes to the
velocity and then the Masters flux to
cross that a lot latitude line they're
actually not bad but like the air is
kind of canceled so up until about 20
minutes ago that wasn't working at all I
was getting stuff that was ludicrously
large like about a hundred times wrong
and I was trying to wrap my brain for
why it was wondering what was happening
and I finally caused it as is always the
case I swear to God ever
every time I have tried to be clever in
this PhD every single time I've been
like oh you know what Chiqui I'm just
gonna I'm just gonna do a little
shortcut there another work you can't
try and be clever in a PhD you have to
be dumb to do one of these you just have
to plot along and not be rash native
because as soon as I did things sort of
the more I don't honestly I was trying
to trying to reuse another variable and
like kinda cheeky bit of manipulation
and it just didn't work did that though
and it now works well I showed you the
stratospheric fields so this is at one
kilometer up this is definitely in the
troposphere and look there's the blue
curve there's an error but it's
basically the right kind of idea is
definitely off set but the red curve
there's just enough information there
whatsoever it's not predicting much of a
density anomaly and then if you look
down velocity it's not bad it's pretty
close in parts but actually yeah about
half of the time it's really close for
the blue Kevin Roker it's just kinda a
plus and then the mass flux again the
air is kind of cancel for the blue curve
but the red curve you're not getting
anything from that up until that moment
I was definitely having one of those
morning's where which happen quite
frequently where I just wasn't really
like connecting with the work and I was
like ah why isn't this working come on
like just throw me a bone here and then
I caught that numerical error I was like
it's suddenly only ah yes come on it's
it's taking pride in the small victories
that's what I've learned is like you
just got to latch onto something like
that and either as a springboard to
motivate yourself into work more so
that's good that now means that I can
run a long version of that that's for
one day what I was just showing you I
want to do that for all those in the
dataset there are 55,000 time steps
so I'll set that right that I'll
probably finish overnight and in the
meantime I've got more stuff to write up
also something that happened this
morning I'm gonna get awkward ly close
yep that's awkwardly close enough how
expressive can't be in my eyes so I had
a rather interesting email today from
Google about something which I can't
talk to you about yet but something very
interesting happened today
I'm really really excited about this one
[Laughter]
[Music]
so it's currently mid-afternoon and much
like yesterday I'm taking a quick for a
out of the office for about an hour
again because of Chapel Choir so
technically I'm not a chorus caller
anymore because I took my four years uni
but some of the bases that they do have
this year ill so I'm definitely not
doing the right house or cuz I didn't
have music
just turning up and singing so this
should be fun and it's dark now so that
was fun
I was sight-reading fairies to heaven by
William Harris which is not the easiest
thing to sing in the world I did the
bass one part before but it's double
quotes to choir singing at the same time
so I did one bass part and I was taking
the other one I think I might have
pushed everybody out key for a little
bit but we were covered in the end and
oh you know you should listen to her by
the way if you don't know it's an
amazing piece of music so it's like
seven now I'm just going to get
something to eat from the marketplace
and then I'm going back to the office to
pick up where I left off earlier with
some of this massive luck stuff which is
going there's a she's starting to work
[Music]
so this evening I've been working on a
new bit of the thesis which only came
into existence a week ago a month until
handin not a problem which is extending
some theory that I derived for the
thesis and basically picking apart
different contributions to it rather
than looking at the coming out sphere as
a whole it's saying like where does this
bit come from where does this become
from I'll fully concede it's been quite
a frustrating evening it's currently 10
o'clock and I'm not going to go home
because I have one quote-unquote I
haven't fixed it it's looking a lot
better than it did and it's making more
sense than it did
I think I'm just gonna let it run
overnight generate a bunch of data and
then see what the statistics on it look
like I have the individual cases I'm
looking at don't look good but it might
be on the whole it's actually okay I'm
just yeah
annoyed very annoyed like the rest of
today has been finding these small
problems and fixing them and improving
and iterating and I feel like this
hasn't followed that pattern this has
been just a crap and it's it's not
working no matter what and I know that
this code is doing exactly what the
theory says it you know I'm done I'm
supplying the code with disk rity
discretized version of the maths but
it's not working
why don't you just write as two things
running on there there's something you
can actually say there's something
running on that computer more things
have been ticked off not as many as I'd
like it might well be that I've actually
worked the stuff out correctly this is
what the theory says it's just that the
theory is bad but like I wasn't
expecting it to be that wrong and I was
expecting it to be wrong in different
places so you know maybe this is right
and this is actually more interesting
but yeah not a happy bunny anyway now's
the time to go home and what am i doing
oh yeah what design work
well that's to do evenings so I was
walking at home and I've calmed down a
bit and who do I bump into look its blog
favorite where bath is - Perkins in
tears - it's been sparse so dan and I
have what we still we still on speaking
terms after I moved out yeah we are
how is the new housemate
it's a different vibe it's safe to say
here is an actual picture of Ed Dunn's
room just a mess so you didn't realize
how lucky you so this is the first time
that you've appeared in the blog for a
while what would you like to catch up
the internet on guys I just could say
there's too many things happening
there's so many things happening he's a
very busy boy he wanted to hear more
from dan and I we have been doing a
weekly podcast and actually has been
weekly for the past two weeks we missed
a couple yeah um be aware we have our
imposter wiki cast and if you like us
then you should just check that out
because it's basically the only way
you're gonna get us together on a
regular basis because although this is
two nights in a row I've bond between
people you've been leaving rehearsal and
I've been leaving work spontaneously to
didn't realize I was just coming home
from makes University singers plug poke
poke poke blow cold though it's bloody
cold it's really really cold it's like
five degrees you can see your breath and
it's ways November
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
hmm hello and welcome back to the PhD
office so yeah today's have been a bit
of a weird one for filming because this
is the first time I'm doing the same to
camera and it's currently quarter to
11:00 in the p.m. so other day today
well I've been working I've been writing
stuff and a thesis been a good day for
getting plots in thesis actually some
really good stuff and writing up and
like page counts going up and yeah
basically things are going well on that
front I then went a home to record the
wiki cast this is me recording the work
you cast and to get some CD stuff
finalized then I came back here at about
like 4:00 and I've been working since
pretty pretty solidly working up until
like 10 of 10 I had dinner here had
another delicious delicious microwave
ready meal and that leads us to here
where I'm gonna put the camera down here
in a different part of the office so
that you know there's a little bit of
variety and then I'm going to talk to
you about what I'm actually doing this
week in terms of research so if you need
to the channel my thesis is an
atmospheric physics specifically I'm
looking at the dynamics of how the
middle layer of the atmosphere the
stratosphere couples to the lower level
lowest level of the atmosphere the
troposphere and the surface we know that
it happens in these events cause sudden
stratospheric warming switch is these
big violent events in the mid atmosphere
and I've basically come up with
hypothesis which is that there's a field
in the stratosphere called the PV field
which causes effects at a distance
basically and when you get a Sun warming
there's a big change in that field and
what I'm looking at is whether that it's
also seen in the far field effect that's
like the that's like the p g---thirteen
simple version so what's new this week
is that I mentioned that you had this
variable PV right it's not just in the
stratosphere you can define PV which
stands for potential vorticity anywhere
in the atmosphere and you can get a
useful thing out of it called the stream
function with from which you can work
out the velocity and the temperature and
all bunch of other stuff like about the
pressure
for example and you get it through a
protest called inversion you invert the
PV to get the stream function
now you can avert any PV distribution to
get an Associated stream function and
there's a form of PV it's like an
approximation to the true value of it
called QG PV or quasi geostrophic
potential vorticity awesome and the cool
thing about that is that it's a linear
equation basically you can take two
blobs of PV but of QG PV and invert this
one and then take that away and invert
this one and take that away combine
those two stream functions that you've
gotten together and it's exactly the
same as if you don't owe them both being
there right it's a superposition if any
of you are doing physics degrees that
might sound familiar because it's
exactly like electrostatics up until
this week I've been inverting so
remember that's how you get the stream
function the useful thing for the PV
I've been inverting the entire qg PV
distribution for the whole northern
hemisphere because that's the way you
get accurate you know velocities and
temperatures and whatnot but what's been
differing this week is that I've
actually been considering just the PV
the qg PV from the top bit which is in
the stratosphere so from about 15
kilometers to about 40 or 50 kilometers
up just using that bit of information
and the point of that is to see yeah ok
one you can invert all the PV PV PV and
see if the quasi geostrophic assumptions
that go into making it if those
assumptions allowing you to do other
stuff in the atmosphere like it allows
you to calculate pressure changes for
example that's one thing which this
thesis is doing but crucially the second
thing is that it's asking the question
can you do that only using that stuff in
the stratosphere in the upper part of
the atmosphere and that's something I
couldn't answer until this week because
I didn't invert just that PV that's what
I've been doing and the short answer to
the question can you do it or just the
stratospheric stuff is it's it's no
does this mean that my hypothesis is
incorrect well I don't know because this
is the first results chapter where I'm
looking at this in a broad context like
does this work for every time step for
every day the year does this work and
the answer seems to be no the signals
just not big enough in the lower part of
the atmosphere when you just consider
stuff that you have you're only using
stratospheric qgp v but the next chapter
is looking at the the huge events the
Sun stratosphere warming's and seeing if
the hypothesis works there
so it's possible but it might still work
my guess is that it won't but I'm
holding out hope but I might get
something interesting to talk of my my
so yeah that's what I've been working on
and writing I know that somebody's going
to ask this yes I'm writing my thesis in
latex the idea of doing it in word makes
me feel physically sick if you're a
psychic certainly in the earth sciences
I have probably getting on 400 equations
in this thesis if not more doing those
in word it'd be a nightmare it's so easy
to do it in latex I also don't have to
worry about my bibliography because I'm
doing that via bid tech and I'm using
Mendeley which is a bit of software will
you put PDS in the papers and then it
will generate a dot bib file stop
bibliography file which think it's red
in my later and it generates the DES
blog Rafi and all your citations
automatically so that's pretty neat I'd
say and also lay tech is kind of
industry standard it makes everything
that nice it means a stuff like table of
contents list of figures list of tables
or stuff they automatically everything
just looks pretty pretty Peng really
looks nice and scientific and because
somebody will also ask this I have no
doubt I am doing it in Kyle which is
fine really
it's got it's got a built-in little
button that you click it and it makes
the it makes your PDF handout to go into
the command line that's pretty cool we
would recommend see ya and things are
kind of coming together it's it's kind
of slow work although you know if you
look at the chapter at the moment
there's a lot of good stuff in here like
this this is now several pages of really
quite solid science there's some good
figures in here
communicates the points I think this is
much much better than it was so honestly
I don't mind staying here until late
because this is the way things get done
you know
no-nothing have no has ever been
achieved without hard work as I don't
mind putting this work in I am very very
tired and it's going to be I think
another three weeks of really intense
effort but then touching words with all
my might here and then we should be done
then I should be done and I should act
can hand him take a break good carts
brakes
I remember those so it's just hit eleven
o'clock I just gonna set one more bit of
code running maybe write a to-do list of
what I'm gonna do tomorrow morning then
I'm gonna go home and I am finalizing
the CD designs and putting the last few
bits like finishing touches in and then
that should be done Hey
well I look kind of crazy I was talking
to pick silver last night and I feel
like writing this thesis at the moment
this chapter because basically the tail
end of is where I wanted it to be anyway
I'm rewriting from the beginning and I
felt like it's almost I when they made
the channel tunnel and they have two
tunnels and they met in the middle when
you're tunneling you don't really know
how far away you are from the other one
you can't see through the rock but
science but I feel like I'm actually
pretty closer to making the two ends
meet then I realize like I'll probably
get to a point writing and be like wait
hang on all this stuff is now still
applicable like I still need to redo
bits and I need to widen that tunnel I
guess I can heed to have another column
to all the plots and to the discussion
but like the structure is there I just
got to kind of keep going until you
break through
again I'm getting that they're getting
to drive me nuts definitely the first
take night game night like time so I'm
back in the office I promise I actually
did leave I had lunch in the RAM
I had a nachos that was meant for two
people but I kind of ate it by myself
anyway I've been working all afternoon
and I just discovered something I've
just discovered something rather cool
about my research that I didn't know
until like an hour ago so before I can
explain what's so interesting about this
figure I need to talk to you about some
math so there's this concept in maths
which is kind of everywhere that people
mostly take for granted called linearity
right and a function which is something
and that's where you it's like I always
think of it as a magic box right and
it's a magic box where you put something
in and you get something out an example
function might be I don't know f is a
function where it takes in two numbers a
and B and it adds them together and the
output you get F of a and B is a plus B
all right now that would be a linear
function because if you were to supply
four numbers to that right if you were
to do a and B f of a and B plus F of C
and D I know is exactly the same as f of
a plus C and B plus D had to think then
an example of a nonlinear function might
be something like F of a equals a
squared and that's not linear because if
you were to do for example
F of a plus F of B that's not the same
as F of a plus B and just to put some
numbers into there phase 2 and B is 3
then 2 plus 3 is 5 so you'd expect the
answer to be 25 at the end 5 squared but
2 squared plus 3 squared isn't 25 that
gonna be four plus nine it's 13 so this
F this function is a nonlinear function
now I have to be careful what I say here
just in case anything from this thesis
gets published which hopefully it will
basically what I'm working with is a
nonlinear function and like I said
yesterday I'm looking at separating out
stratospheric influence on something
right so if it was a linear function one
working with you could take the
tropospheric information and the
stratospheric information put them in
separately add them together and then
you get the full atmosphere response
this isn't P V inversion I'm talking
about by the way this is some other like
combination it's actually taking the
output of that PV inversion of stream
function and doing some calculations on
point is the calculations on doing on
that stream function are nonlinear when
I looked at the two fields separately
basically the tropospheric field was
really big which is what I expected and
the stress field was pretty small like
the results of this calculation right I
mean which is mass boxes them
stratospheric field wasn't really
predicting much mass flux near the
surface expected the tropospheric field
was again I was expecting but what I
wasn't expecting was mâche so that at
the top there is what you see in the
real world well kind of reanalysis is a
weird thing and that one below is what
you get if you invert the PV in the
whole atmosphere you work out the mass
fluxes and that's that's a lot of what
that is that one below that is what you
do if you do the stratosphere in
isolation and that's what you get if you
look at the strata for an isolation and
you'll notice that they're pretty much
if you add them together you're gonna
get something like that but there's this
interference term between them and that
interference term is the non-linear part
of that equation where it's this kind of
cross term if you like the thing to
remember is that what i just showed you
is the mass flux at a particular height
so as in at 10 kilometers exactly 10
kilometers just how much mass is being
thrown into the polar region which is
what i'm doing all this except that's
all well and good doing me wrong
but what i'm doing with this mass flux
is using it to predict pressure changes
so I'm not just interested in the mass
flux at a particular height I'm
interested in all the mass fluxes at
that high and above like I'm vertically
integrating if you've done high-level
math
and vertically integrating that mass
flux field above that point and if you
do that something interesting happens
because for this particular set of data
that's the observations at the top
that's what the inversion predicts and
you're like they're actually once you
start looking through it they are
actually kind of similar the magnitudes
are off but like the patterns kind of
they're the stratospheric stuff again
it's basically just in the stratosphere
above the black line which is the
boundary between the stratosphere in the
troposphere the tropospheric information
is kind of as it was and you know if you
add those two together you're gonna get
something looks a bit like that but this
interference - hello hello sunshine
this interference term for example here
right there's a big negative event and
you see it that's the total which is the
sum of this and this but those two
aren't out of that big this interference
term is though that nonlinear term is
nice and juicy so that will go some way
to actually predicting the tropospheric
impact of this sort of descending mass
flux this descending pressure anomaly
what that's saying is that the
stratosphere on its own like the
stratospheric stream function on its own
doesn't flux mass into the troposphere
in a significant way but the way that
the stratospheric stream function
interacts with the troposphere extreme
function does flux mass and arguably it
flux is mass of same water magnitude or
greater order of magnitude than the
tropospheric stream function does on its
own that's really kind of cool so that's
what I'm going to be here for the next
few hours doing it's currently actually
it's only half past six so I probably
have liked to somewhere hours and then I
need to go home example dinner with me
and I fancy actually cooking maybe be
honest we're not cooking tonight are we
silent and I got to do some editing
everybody's favorite section of the vlog
and we're back here again it's mostly
getting very very boring for you imagine
what it's like for me I'm doing the wiki
cast it's 10 o'clock so I'll probably
editing this for another two hours or so
because the podcast by an hour and a
half and then it takes a little bit more
than just the time to listen to it it's
pretty lights to be honest like doing a
video for two hours would be weeks of
but podcast is that's doable
actually while still on the subject to
podcast so I listened to a few not many
podcast like my dad wrote a porno which
is hilarious if you if you don't listen
to it check it out
BBC's more or less in our time I do
listen to hello internet but that's not
like a long podcast so I don't I don't
listen as much as I used to but apart
from that I don't listen to a huge
number if you could recommend any
podcast to me that you think I find
interesting please do comment down there
because I'm always on the lookout for
new stuff to listen to but ticketing it
comes to like long journeys so yeah be
trusted to niall thoughts now we need to
get back to work man that took longer to
finish than I thought it would is
quarter to one and I'm gonna go to bed
well I mean I'm I'm on the bed now I'm
gonna get in the bed and I'm gonna go to
sleep I'm gonna go pay office tomorrow
morning and continue rising up and doing
a little bit more statistics that need a
few more stats that need to be done
before I can write them up into the
thesis and then hopefully get really
close to finishing this chat off
tomorrow if I could
yeah I could definitely do it this week
just got to keep pushing tomorrow is a
very special day it's a first for me I'm
gonna do something that I've never done
before and it's unique to this part of
the world I'm really excited
[Music]
no no happy not that
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
and
[Music]
you
[Music]